тому украинцам потребно датчика тыс а до
включения маргулана вы знаете я сделал
своей жизни более тысячи интервью я не
скрою были люди ну может 50 может сто
которая меня перевернули буквально вот
маргулан систем баев из этой когорты
людей я шел на интервью с ним ну не
конечно было интересно я всегда делаю
интервью исходя из интереса
но человек думаю стал в казахстане
миллиардером построил бизнес вышел на
лондонскую биржу там 4 по моему или 5
миллиардов стоил его бизнес долларов на
известный уважаемый философ ну думаю
наверняка интересно конечно и вот когда
он начал говорить я почувствовал что я в
него как в человека влюбляюсь
это поразительная история он меня взял
сразу одной фразой он был
чабаном его отец чабан и он был чем
кабаном на краю казахстана советское
время и вот он мне рассказывает я спал в
кошаре с овцами и баранами однажды я
вышел в степь вечером марево такое дымка
и меня пронзила мысль не для того я
родился на свет чтобы пасти свою еду у
я услышал это мне стал уже интересным и
он дальше рассказал как этот чабан
мальчик из глухого аула как он рванул
благодаря себе не потому что у него папа
был какой-то миллиардер там или политик
не потому что его кто-то тянул за уши за
руки за ноги
благодаря себе благодаря тому что он
получил образование настойчиво благодаря
тому что он работал он работает сейчас
он сейчас
успешный и блогер и образовать или
меценат и у него огромное количество
проектов инвест проектов по всему миру
человек работает не покладая рук и ходит
в скромненько и футболочки в джинсиках
кроссовках не обязательно показывать и
и очень скромный удивительно скромные я
еще раз понял главное чем человек больше
тем он скромнее чем человек меньше тем
он конфликт не и зле и ему хочется
обязательно чтобы о нем говорили причем
хорошо
вопросы мы будем называть дмитрием
ильичом вместе и вместе с вами дорогие
наши телезрители потому как как мы и
обещали маргулан снг уже с нами на связи
прямо сейчас маргулан добрый вечер
спасибо что приперся как мы перейдем к
предметным вопросам коротко вот может у
нас очень много молодых зрителей нам
писали сегодня 14 18 16 назовите три
вещи которые вы с которых вы начинаете
день вот может как бы вы посоветовали
или вы посоветовали бы молодым людям с
чего бы стоило начинать свой день чтобы
возможно возможно стать успешный человек
спасибо большое очень рад был у вас в
эфире
можно до того как и отлично этот вопрос
я по коррупции простая суда пожалуйста и
шут нашу дискуссию по коррупции на старт
смотрите коррупция же что такое
коррупция это алчность
плюс возможность минус контроль и вот
эти три важные вещи то есть когда вы
даете большую заработную плату
чиновникам
вы только сокращаете их алчность но
просто сокращения алчности мало нужно
еще убирать у них возможность и
увеличивать контроль вот три вещи я
считаю для того чтобы бороться с
системной коррупции то системно бороться
с коррупцией если
о том как я начинаю свой день каждый
день я свой день начиная одинаково у
меня прописанной прописан стандарт моей
рутины
но так как я занимаюсь в основном не то
что основном очень много социальных
сетями и так далее первым пунктом у меня
ну понятно по а после
гигиены первым пунктом у меня идет
проверка мессенджеров я проверяю
мессенджеры
и отвечаю на все вопросы вопросы которые
накопились за ночь потому что десять
часов я обычно уже сплю и за за ночь
кто-то мире мне пишут очень многие я
отвечаю только рано после после гигиены
то 1 прав фирмами 2 я что делаю это я
проверяю социальные сети но не более
полчаса в день
полчаса дней пас просматриваю количество
подписчиков какие-то комменты меня если
зацепили отвечу язь не зацепили то там
ребята девчатами есть они ответят или
или мне перенаправить а это второй умер
и третье самое главное с чего я начинаю
день бунта говорит вот этот блок ответ
на мессенджеры социальные сети то можно
вообще как одну задачу сделать бунт
социальные отношения второй блок это
планирование планирование дня пересмотр
планов дня планировать для планирования
и деле планирование месяца и так далее я
все время каждый день делал апдейт
планов утром-вечером утром-вечером
дальше 3 блока такой один час к 1 час
это специальный час в течение которого я
думаю о том как оптимизировать свою
работу как оптимизировать свой день как
сделать его еще более эффективнее что я
делаю не так что можно улучшить какую
книгу прочитать
плане саморазвития и так далее так далее
вот эти три главных шага и что они
формируют полностью весь мой день
посоветуете потом чуть позже
нашим зрителям какие книги прочитать
проблема с совета вания книг она через
неправильный вопрос я считаю потому что
книги иначе надо читать четко понимать
для чего книги читается под задачу то
есть когда у вас есть проблема нужно
читать книги для решения проблем
когда у вас есть цель и вам нужно
достичь какой-то цели вы не знаете
что-то надо читай книги только для
решения вот этого либо а книги нужно
читать для расширения своего творческого
потенциала то есть вы четко должны
понимать что знание бывают лишними мы
сейчас перешли в такую информационную
эпоху когда знание бывает лишним не amd
ошская даже так сказал что мудрость
прибавляется за счет вычитания знаний
эрудированность прибавляется за счет
прибавления знаний так вот
эрудированность не имеет ничего общего с
вашей эффективностью в жизни с вашей
эффективностью на вашу эффективность
влияет ваша мудрость
у вас уже достаточно тех знаний для того
чтобы устроить свою жизнь неплохо я бы
даже сказал хорошо проблема в том что мы
знание собираем коллекционируем и наша
голова превращается в чердак не нужных
знаний мы как будто мы себя готовим как
будто всю жизнь собираемся зарабатывать
на разгадывание кроссвордов на самом
деле надо больше думать голова это не
хранилище знаний голова это процессор по
обработке знаний поэтому и так по уровню
если я скажу техники которые я читаю то
простому человеку они абсолютно
бесполезны я бы я буду что они вредны
понял хорошо вопрос снимается скажите
пожалуйста вы были партнером михаила
саакашвили работая в украине но в конце
марта объявили что не хотите заниматься
политикой и перестаете быть партнером
михаил николаевич а в чем причина но во
первых сразу забегая вперед скажу что
smile
михаил у меня прекрасные отношения ящик
то его эффективнейшим политикам есть
политики знаете есть политики демагоги
из политики ораторы и он политика
реформатор потому что отлично политика
реформатора от политика оратора
том что он и говорить и делать вот это
очень важное качество михаила мыслим
прекрасных отношениях
он меня поддерживает я его всегда
поддерживаю то есть мы абсолютно это не
личностный вопрос дело в том что когда я
стал партнером михаил саакашвили у меня
было три задачи которая на себя взял это
выстраивание отношений офиса простых
решений с бизнесом а второе организация
международной деятельности во все
простых решений и третье это анализ и
предложений по повышению эффективности
законодательного процесса в украине по
всем по всем трем направлениям про была
проделана большая огромная работа и я
вам скажу что ситуация со скоростью
законодательного процесса
значительно улучшилась это та часть
невидимая работы которые простому
обывателю и и не видать но она оказывает
сильнейшее эффект на работу госаппарата
приведу пример вы знаете в 2020 году
верховная рада рассмотрела чуть более
чуть более 4000 законопроектов чуть
более 4 тысяч из них три с половиной
тысячи почти инициировали депутаты то
есть получается
верховная рада плодилась законодательный
спам просто
законы и законы законы в то же время на
другой стороне вы знаете исполнительной
дисциплины в украине просто с этим делом
решение судов не исполняется вам нужно
больше сокращать законы они генерит дело
в том что верховна рада работает
парадигме
как завод который должен работать на
стол проценту мощность и производить как
можно больше законов не в этом же суть
так вот мое предложение было о том что
кардинально резко нужно сократить план
законопроектных работ и в начале года
сразу совместно там верховная рада
кабмин президент договориться о каком-то
плане законопроект работ и он любит
очень маленькие так вот сейчас
последнего феврале по крайней
я разговаривал с русланом алексей чем
стефан жуком они пришли вроде в 657
законопроектов хотели снизить до 350
но если будет 500 законопроектов в плане
законопроекта работ это уже лично я
хороший большой шаг который увеличит не
качество то законопроектов и скорость
дальше
вынесен проект закона о новой регламенте
верховной раде потому что регламент
утверждается законом верховной раде
синхронизированная эти системы кабмина
верховной рады первый зампред верховной
радой приз или президента в раде
русланович телефончик сейчас лично
курирует вопросы эффективности а моей
многие предложения рефреном звучали надо
последним мартовском съезде партии слуга
народу и где и зеленский давил на
эффективность государственного про то и
се патчук целую презентацию по этому
поводу дел я не говорю что это я все-все
я просто говорю что сильно какое-то
моих идей попало и люди просто начали
реально заниматься генерить в этом
направлении много хороших вещей очень
большую работу проделать это амин цифра
федоров алексей выступ первый зампред
они реально делают большую пакет работам
у нас мы определить двадцать пять
быстрых побед в этом направлении короче
я считаю что вот то что я спою функцию
рассматривал как посеять семена я не
могу эти реформы провести сам потому что
мне нет полномочий но посеять семена
анголы государственных чиновников
я думаю по крайней мере высокомерно
думаю что мне это удалось может быть нет
не знаю но я так думаю понятно то есть
вы сами по сути выполнили до свою задачу
с которой шли ради которые согласились
поработать с офисом простых решений
ну и теперь вас фокус внимания
переместился на другу
смотрите у меня вот те были три задачи
но у меня ещё была задача внутренняя для
меня лично мне лично было интересно
узнать работа государственного аппарата
вообще посмотреть насколько законно
эффективности работают на
государственной службе так вот когда я
изучил посмотрел я еще раз убедился что
государственная служба это место где в
первую очередь надо внедрять законной
эффективности потому что к сожалению из
всех видов человеческой деятельности на
сегодня
единственное где мы можете as можете
оставаться неэффективными годами это
государственная служба
если вы не эффективность спортсмен тувы
вас никто не будет помнить если вы не
эффективный артист вы где-то на
задворках будете если вы не эффективный
бизнес мир вы банкрот
единственная область человеческой
деятельности где можно оставаться
неэффективным годами поэтому лучше стул
принципиально важно внедрить
эффективность сначала в госорганах
потому что государство является
ограничителем узким горлышком все
экономики не расширить эффективность
государственной
государства эффективность реактивность
госуправления страна не может
развиваться димент динамично это и вы
собрать lancer государство это слабейшее
звено государстве это слабейшее звено
которых тормозит все понятно очень
имя послышалось но мне кажется очень
милая
такая фраза не послышалось что бизнесмен
не бизнесмена бизнесмен но не интересно
интересно много новые тока дмитрий
гордон
у нас застала в нашей студии митрич вас
до возможность маргулан добрый вечер я
бы несколько вопросов задал если вы не
возражаете скажите пожалуйста на ваш
взгляд стоит зеленскому встречаться с
путиным а вы знаете на уровне во первых
не мне судить отношении глав государств
но это вырос вы спрашиваете моё мнение
гипотетически теоретическое я считаю что
в любой глава государства это не человек
это функция внешняя политика строится не
на человеческих отношениях симпатиях и
антипатиях
она строится только на интересах страны
если это в интересах украины он обязан
встречаться если это где-то противоречит
интересам украины он не должен
встречаться другой вопрос здесь
накладывается второй слой называют так
называемой стратегия если ты заведомо
знаешь вот ты идешь навстречу если идешь
представлять интересы страны их
отстаивать но при этом стратегически
понимаешь что можешь проиграть
да надо уклоняться потому что
единственный способ победить в любой
войне это уклониться от войны навстречу
надо идти только имея высокие шансы
получить тот результат который мужчин
твоей стране как однажды сказала на
руководитель нам не понравилось руку x1
спецслужбы сша говорит забудьте о слове
честный поединок между нами и
террористами не может быть честным
поединком мы идем только и если у нас
есть 10 кратное превышение силе и мы ему
не оставляем ни малейшего шанса
а идти на переговоры что пятьдесят на
пятьдесят
авось получится я считаю вот здесь
большая опасность маргулан мы много
говорили сейчас о том что в украине
хотят
[музыка]
проголосовать закон о деолигархизация
ну что на мой взгляд очень здорово вот
вы простой чабан
отец чабан я уже рассказывал и сегодня
тоже как вы вышли все из кошары где жили
собственные баранами и сказали не для
того я родился на свет что почти свою
еду до дословно это так звучит в изделии
да вы сделали себя сами вас нельзя
назвать олигархам но тем не менее
скажите вот вы долго учились вы много
учились вы учились в разных странах на
лондонской бирже ваша компания во
сколько было оценено но во-первых я
хотел бы внести определенную точность
мой отец был агроном я чем по
сельских юном я чабан это во первых во
вторых все таки это не только моя
заслуга да я работал я пахал о чем у
бога но все-таки во первых а мне повезло
просто повезло ещё плюс к тому же потому
что элемент удачи очень важен и второй
момент это мое окружение конечно которой
меня все время поддерживала и моей
команды а это конечно очень важно и
берта то что касается лондонской биржи
оценка была я вывел свой банду ты
седьмом году оценка было четыре
миллиарда долларов я кстати был очень
недоволен потому что это по нижней
границе но на тот момент просто уже
начали сыпаться ипотечный рынок сша я
ожидал что будет 7 миллиардов честно да
вот скажите пожалуйста каким бы вы
сделали закону деолигархизация осмотрите
для начала нужно четко разобраться в
терминах по иначе можно ребенка
выплеснуть вместе с водой что такое
олигарх я считаю вот олигарх это тот
человек который практически делает
бизнес на государстве не на свободном
рынке она государстве используя
административные и политические или иной
ресурс вот это олигарх вот здесь можно
четко разделить как сиамским били
близнецов просто просто надо резать
это надо резать это я полностью согласен
если закон будет поддержат подрывает
этого это к сожалению многие под
олигархами понимает такую вещь что это
крупный капитал
нет крупный капитал трогать нельзя не в
коем случае вместе он сформировался
нормально там тем более если масса нами
капитал и он если не участвовать
государственном управлении
не влезает они покупают депутатов и так
далее так далее в этом плане я что нужно
четко понимать с терминами но это нужно
понимать это очень тонкая грань и когда
в дело вступит лоббисты
потому что вы же не батуми не вселенной
работать и стране и начнут label кажется
интересным я очень боюсь что этот закон
выйдет очень крым и вы напугайте
добросовестных предпринимателей и
бизнесменов как инвестиции тем более
суда перестанут идти потому что
вооружившись популистскими лозунгами и
вырванными из контекста этого закона
начнут выступать политики цен набирать
себе очки я бы сказал так это скользкая
дорожка
как и где лучше бы двигаться очень
крайне осторожно мы сегодня говорили о
том что на одной из программ савика
шустера на канале украина
михаил саакашвили на с помощью графиков
таблиц наглядно
объяснил и рассказал что оказывается
ежегодно в украине воруется 37
миллиардов долларов много ли
или мало это и как сделать так чтобы все
эти деньги вернулись в бюджет украины
вот смотрите вот этот вопрос я бы
связался предыдущем вопросом по знакомым
о деолигархизация мой подход был бы так
ребята вы не занимайтесь dio
олигархи зации вы займитесь один бизнес
бизнес низации государства где без не
связаться и государства проблема же
олигархов о том что бунт любого человека
и бизнесмена у него в природе в матрице
прописано делать зарабатывать деньги это
его природная или и туроператоры рудное
желание авторитета общественная функция
который ему прописано ты зарабатывает
деньги твои от лица зарабатывать деньги
посредством создания ценности для членов
общества но проблема же олигархи идет о
том что босс чиновники лизуна бизнес а
кот если у гость чиновников начать
отнимать возможности и олигархи пропадут
ведь кто дает олигархам возможности
государства и дает возможности поэтому я
здесь полностью солидарна с михаилом
вы просто начни терезы пункции был пусть
по чиновников выбивает а те сферы на
которых они делают деньги максимально
попытайся приватизировать то что можно
кроме отдельных секторов которые
отвечают за инфраструктуру у государства
безопасности так поэтому если вы пойдёте
по поводу по пути уменьшения
регулирования уменьшение зависимости
бизнес от государства
а чем меньше у государства останется
функционала тем меньше будет плене
олигархов то есть я считаю что где
бизнесе зация государственного аппарата
важнее чем деолигархизация бизнеса
маргулан согласны ли вы с тем что в
течение пяти лет могут полностью
пропость наличные деньги ну во-первых
смотрите топ недооценил по поводу 37
миллиардов много или мамка это просто
колоссальная сумма колоссальная сумма по
почему потому что эта сумма вырванная из
оборота это просто колоссальный урон
есть она up
идет в оборот стране то надо посмотреть
какой цикл у вас оборота вообще в целом
стране а по денежным агрегатом то это
совокупность но если брать два наоборот
а то это 70 80 миллиардов экономического
оборота может обслужить этом вытащенная
сумма
это в один год а он уже имеют еще
накопительный эффект поэтому смотрите
всегда вопрос такой есть такая такая
математика 1 процента если путем
сложного процента взять один процент и
умножать и увеличивать на 1 процент то
разница в конце года между одним
стартовым процентам одним и 099
просто колоссальная здесь работает такая
сложная математика проблем они даже не
просто этих 37 миллиардов
атташе 37 миллиардов вырванной из
экономики не обслуживают товара денежный
оборот на сумму под 70 миллиардов то
есть там много таких побочных эффектов
книга я уже не говорю про то что
ломается очень много рыночных сигналов в
самой сам на на в самом рынке теперь то
что касается наличных денег мы же
говорим только наличный денежный оборот
за пять лет ни как не может исчезнуть
наличный оборот по самом деле я не верю
в том что про будет полностью потому что
это связано с психологией людей не все
люди захотят отказаться но я считаю что
значительно уменьшить это вполне по
силам и вполне реально с учетом нынешних
технологий но меня чуть-чуть арене
чуть-чуть о даже достаточно сильно
напрягает то что государство опять у вас
в украине полезно в регулировании
комиссии банковской комиссии смотрите
европа не может перейти до сих пор не
может прийти на полосу безналичный
оборот потому что там банковской
комиссии дожали до такого уровня что им
не выгодно
развивать pos-терминалы им невыгодно
развивать платежные системы и во многих
странах
италия германия ты достал до сих пор до
сушки бы пластик либо кеш
у нас в казахстане я уже последние 3
года конечно не видел в руках не держал
у меня и тут и это часы iphone все
мельника не пользуется у нас в
казахстане там kaspi bank еще там это
внедряют платежной системы очень удобно
систем платежей минкин пытается бороться
минфин потратили
загнать ее в прокрустово ложе налоговой
системы
но наши блага марции что не наломали
дров я считаю что сначала надо дать
удобства людям а потом начинать думать
как с этого удобства государства что-то
поиметь но это опять таки должно не
самоцелью уничтожить безнал смотрите на
когда у вас сама цель уничтожить безнал
для того чтобы загнать людей в
прозрачной поле это похоже как баранов
загоняет в кошару загон а когда вы
говорите нет мы с наша цель создать
максимально удобства удобства для людей
платить безналом тогда люди сами
добровольно идут в это поле а потом вы
начинаете думать а теперь как бы с этого
нам что-то помочь и не монетизирует
государства идти назад интересов людей
про интересы людей я бы хотел спросить
потому как я у нас время наше эфирное к
сожалению ограничено а я обещал что вы
дадите совет
украинцам как возможно инвестировать во
что лучше инвестировать
даже если речь идет там не о больших
деньгах если мы говорим да
[музыка]
рядовой я не люблю это слово рядовом
украинцы но мы поймем что у кого-то есть
сто долларов у кого-то есть 1000
долларов у кого-то больше меньше как эти
цифры эти суммы можно приумножить и где
возможно менее рисковые какие отрасли
как инвестировать как в этом разобраться
если ты в этом ничего не понимаешь
смотреть этот вопрос мне очень часто
задают делать наш том что проблема в том
что это пояс серебряной пули у меня есть
целая лекция который называется отличие
психологии богатых людей от бедных людей
такое бедные люди как правило хотят все
много и сразу а как лотерейном билете но
к сожалению жизнь от не работает любой
совет который я сейчас дам им вести в
инвестиционном процессе большое место
занимает t'aime
какое я могу сейчас сказать инвестирует
условно в кирпичи и это будет потеря
денег через полгода оказывается чтоб
именно кирпичи является золотым ключиком
к богатству то есть очень важно понимать
во что инвестировать но нет не менее
важно понимать когда в это инвестировать
потому что вы же должны понимать
динамику этого актива я лучше вам дам
рекомендации на это касается и
украинского государства и простого
рядового гражданина как выразить
удар по гражданина украины любого
граждан и и гражданина украины
независимо вам богатый бизнесмен или там
победит у такси или вообще безработны
опор три важные рекомендации которые я в
свое время услышал ауры и далее
основателя крупнейшего хедж-фонда
присмотр те кто в америке но я как
обычно переделал его на свой лад потому
что я посчитал что это мне совсем все
как бы точно
и рекомендации первое или кстати эти
рекомендации работает на любой этап
рынка на подъеме на спаде в кризисе и
так далее 1 не позволяйте вашим долгам
расти быстрее чем ваши доходы потому что
кризис ваши долги приведут вас к
катастрофе
то есть небо
валяйте вашим долгам расти быстрее чем
ваши доходы это первое правило всегда и
везде работает второе правило не
позволяйте вашим ценам и доходам расти
быстрее чем ваша производительность
иначе вы потеряете конкурентоспособность
то есть у вас производительность низкая
а цены высокие
вы просто потеряете
конкурентоспособность на такую маржу
сразу появятся конкуренты государств
поэтому не позволяете вашим ценам и
доходам расти быстрее чем ваша
производительность на чем вы потеряете
конкурентоспособность и третье правило
делайте все возможное для того чтобы
повысить вашу эффективность ведь
долгосрочной перспективе имеет значение
только эффективность вот три правила на
все случаи жизни и начинает государства
до простого человека работает как день и
ночь
маргулан к сожалению вопросов у меня
много еще осталось копилке
я вас буду приглашать еще к эфиру если у
вас будет такая возможность по тому как
желание пообщаться
огромное вам спасибо большое с
удовольствием василий спасибо вам
спасибо дмитрий
рад вас видеть ухе с вами оказаться за
одним экраном за одним столом это для
меня большое удовольствие и честь оси
следа взаимного гулан спасибо села
большая вам маргулан маргулан систем
борьба с нами на связи